I was almost aborted
my mom got pregnant with me when she was
15. my dad was 17 at the time and he was
a drug dealer so having an abortion
getting rid of this old lump of cells
would have been a pretty convenient move
for both of them
my mom got pregnant again a year or two
after she had me and she had an abortion
then so they took out one of my siblings
my mom and her sister combined got
pregnant five times when they were in
their teens they had three abortions and
me and my cousin Brandy forty percent
survival rate for the original five
my mom had another abortion when I was a
teenager another sibling gun and then
she had my two brothers
I'm glad my mom didn't abort me because
I had some pretty dope stuff to do as
you're about to see in this very video
now the abortion debate usually centers
around issues like when human personhood
begins and what rights a woman has over
what goes on in her own body but as with
most moral debates I think about this in
terms of Imaging God and degrading the
image of God
let's read a quick passage from the
opening chapter of the Bible Genesis 1
verses 26 through 28. then God said let
us make man in our image after our
likeness and let them have dominion over
the fish of the sea and over the birds
of the heavens and over the livestock
and over all the Earth and over every
creeping thing that creeps on the earth
so God created man in his own image in
the image of God he created him male and
female he created them and God blessed
them and God said to them be fruitful
and multiply and fill the Earth and
subdue it and have dominion over the
fish of the sea and over the birds of
the heavens and over every living thing
that moves on the earth now in my video
Norm Macdonald the image of God we
discussed what it means to be created in
the image of God the Bible never gives a
clear explanation of what the phrase
image of God means but when we examine
the main passage in Genesis 1 we see
that it has something to do with three
relationships man's relationship with
God man's relationship with other human
beings and man's relationship with
nature human beings both male and female
can image God in these relationships in
another video Mark Zuckerberg the image
of God we saw another important
component of the doctrine drawn from the
larger context of Genesis 1. the passage
about man being created in God's image
is immediately preceded by God creating
the universe God creates God creates God
creates God creates God creates God
creates and then God creates Man In His
Image after his likeness one possible
implication of the passage in context is
that man is supposed to image God in
creating like when we make epic videos
but now we're going to look at another
way human beings image God namely in
producing children
in Genesis chapter 5 we read this is the
book of the generations of Adam when God
created man he made him in the likeness
of God male and female he created them
and he blessed them and named them man
when they were created when Adam had
lived 130 years he fathered a son in his
own likeness after his image and named
him Seth God created man in his likeness
then Adam fathered a son in his own
likeness after his image I've seen a lot
of people claim that when the Bible says
Adam fathered a son in his own likeness
it means that Adam's Offspring were no
longer the image of God because of sin
and the fall so Adam and Eve were
created in the image of God but they
sinned so their children were no longer
the image of God
but we can't agree with an
interpretation that contradicts what
other passages about the image of God
say and Genesis 9 6 and James 3 9 say
that people long after sin and the fall
are still created in the image and
likeness of God
at most you could say that since Adam
fathers a son in his own likeness he
fathers a son who no longer images God
properly even though he's still the
image of God you could also say that
since Adam's descendants are the image
of God and the image of Adam we're
constantly confronted with a choice the
choice of whether to image God in our
relationships with others or to image
Adam in those relationships when we
image God we somehow reflect the Eternal
nature of God when we image Adam we
reflect a kind of selfishness that seeks
to replace god with something else
but let's think about how human beings
image God in producing children in
Genesis 1 26 God says let us make man in
our image after our likeness let us make
man in our image after our likeness
when you first read this you might think
that God is talking to the Angels or
something but man isn't created in the
image of angels this is the Triune God
man is created in the image of the
Triune God
based on this verse some have claimed
that God is telling us that each human
being is a kind of Trinity composed of
Body Soul and Spirit
but there's nothing in this passage
about Body Soul and Spirit there is
however a unity and a diversity in this
passage that has to do with human beings
where's the unity God creates man
where's the diversity male and female
watch what happens when we go back to
Genesis 5.
a sun is generated within Eve's body Eve
with some help from Adam generates a son
remember Eve is the image and likeness
of God Eve who is the image of God
generates a son who is the image of God
and thus Eve and her son image the
Eternal generation of God the son within
the nature of the trinity
keep in mind a human being generating
another human being is very very
different from Eternal Generation all of
the ways we image God are finite
temporal reflections of the infinite
Eternal God
but Eve generating a son does image the
Eternal generation of the Divine son
look more closely at this passage and
you'll see something else
male and female were both named man
the Hebrew word for man here is Adam
So Adam is a generic name for Humanity
similar to our word Mankind in fact many
translations translate man here as
mankind
but there's also a specific person who's
named Adam the word Adam can refer to
humanity in general but it can also
refer to a specific man
So Adam is Adam Adam the person is Adam
the kind of thing human beings are
but Eve is Adam as well Eve the person
is Adam the kind of thing human beings
are Seth is also Adam Seth the person is
Adam the kind of thing human beings are
Adam the person is not Eve the person
Eve the person is not Seth the person
Seth the person is not Adam the person
but Adam is Adam Eve is Adam and Seth is
Adam look familiar it should it looks
very similar to a conceptual diagram of
the trinity
to be clear once again the Triune God is
very very different from human beings
and from Human Relationships the Triune
God and the relationships within the
Triune God are infinite and eternal
human beings are finite temporal images
of the infinite Eternal divine nature
persons of the Trinity share the same
Divine Essence human persons function as
separate beings
but a man and a woman producing a child
a man whose Adam and a woman whose Adam
producing a child whose Adam a man who's
the image of God and a woman who's the
image of God producing a child who's the
image of God does reflect something
about the Eternal nature of God
so human beings are created in the image
of God and we image God in a lot of
different ways we image God in our ever
increasing dominion over the natural
world we image God in our relationships
with other people we image God in our
love for the persons of the Trinity we
image God when we create things we also
image God when we produce children
when a woman who's the image of God
becomes pregnant another image of God is
actualized within her
before there was only the potential to
produce another image of God the
potential to image God by producing the
image of God
but at conception the image of God is
actualized meaning that unless something
stops IT The Offspring generated within
her will continue to develop the
capacities to image God
in generating an offspring the woman
images God by producing someone who is
the image of God in generating an
offspring the woman and her child image
the Eternal generation of the Sun
in sharing the same human nature with
the man and their offspring while
remaining distinct persons the woman and
the man and their offspring image the
Triune nature of their creator in whose
image they were created
but the man and the woman also image our
original parents and so when the woman
becomes pregnant when the image of God
is actualized within her
either the woman alone or the man and
the woman together have a choice the
choice to either reflect the Eternal
divine nature or